it's amazing what you can accomplish
when you have no choice most of the hard
decisions and the hard times like I
didn't have an option they seem like
choices and they seem like tough guy I
just I didn't perceive a choice like I
was like I just have to keep going when
I quit my job it was like death or do
this and so then I did it I think
honestly a lot of the time when it was
when it was really tough I just didn't
give myself time to dwell on it I just
honestly didn't think about it like I
knew I was screwed and so it's like well
that's not helpful like what else like
what can I do four people who are going
through it you can't lose if you don't
quit like most games worth playing in
life for infinite meaning like the point
of the game is to keep the game going